My name is Sep Kamvar. I am a professor in computer science
and applied math at Stanford. And before that, I was the
engineering lead for personalization at Google. And before
that, I had a small company called Kaltix, which was a
personalized search engine, which got acquired by Google in
2003.
My name is Seth. I was with GSB '06, but left in '05, and
left because I co-founded Meebo along with two other co-
founders. And Meebo started as just a web IM client, it was
like, hey let people get on to AOL or MSN at the time via
the web. We quickly heard from people that they wanted Meebo
in their sites fundamentally to be a social platform in
their sites. So today Meebo is distributed through thousands
of sites, it's on philly.com or Entertainment Weekly or TMZ
as the social platform in that sites, so it lets users
connect up with their friends on Facebook or Twitter or
MySpace or whatever kind of friends they want to connect
with when they go around the web.
My name is Amit Kapur. I run a company called Gravity and we
focus on personalizing the internet. Before Gravity, I was
at MySpace, I was the COO there, where I worked up for a lot
of times since it was a start up, helped build up a lot of
socialization, social media on the web. And before that I
studied mechanical engineering here. So that's my
background, I don't have a business background or anything,
but I really enjoyed my time here and it's nice to be on the
other side of the classroom.
My name is Babak Pahlavan. I did
[inaudible] Berkeley Computer Science in 2006. I joined
[inaudible] Stanford. Basically, I was going to do my PhD
here. It wasn't exactly realized half year through, it wasn'
t exactly my cup of tea, left in 2008. Started Clever Sense,
it's a personalization and mission
[inaudible] as it relates to location based services. We
focus on the locals for mobile. And yeah we started from
2008 to 2010, got founded 2010 and we are powering through
[inaudible]
Hi and I am the moderator. My name is Howard Hartenbaum. I
work at a firm called August Capital, which is kind of a
low-key firm, you may not have heard of. But you have
probably heard of many of the companies that the partners
there have backed including Seagate, Symantec, Compaq,
Intuit, Microsoft, Atheros, Xylink, Sybase and bunch of
others. My lucky entrance into the venture business was, I
put the first money in the Skype and was on their board,
which was really a wild ride. So if you guys have
interesting companies in the future, I am the guy you come
and talk to. So let's talk about the topic and I have a few
questions and I thought some of them, I will just go down
and some of them, we will just be directed at one particular
person. So on the first question, I will start with Babak
and maybe we will go down the line, which is you know
companies here are based on the premise that your users are
willing to input their personal data as part of using the
service and can you explain what types of data that people
are wiling to share using your services and what's the value
that you provide in return for them doing that?
[Informal Talk]
So part of the good news is that, we are living in a Y
generation, I mean people are living practically on Facebook
and Twitter right now. So as far as,
[inaudible] what kind of data we will be asking for, the way
our service works, we are analyzing the conversations that
we are seeing on the web as people are writing reviews and
whatnot on different particular outlets. So we have a new
web indexing user-generated content, so people can actually
use our service without they sharing anything with us, once
we full out launch it. But then they can further share with
us, we are Facebook Connect, totally opt-in service Facebook
Connect or image the Foursquare in Twitter. So it's totally
an opt-in service, so people can share how much that they
want to share. I mean privacy is a big deal thing,
basically, we are not going to build the service, we are not
going to use ourselves, so we believe in absolute matter of
giving control to users. So if there is going to be a button
on our service that it can delete everything that got with
us and they can see it, so that's how we see it.
Well just as some kind of basic background on, I think just
data in general, so I think all of us sort of experienced
this notion of information overload, where over time the
technologies for the creation of content are often competing
with the technologies for the distribution, the discovery of
content. And so what we end up finding is that major
technology companies will come in and create things that
will filter that content, filter that data for us, so that
we find more relevance within it. And early on, you had
companies create directories then you had companies create
search, ultimately even those types of filters ended up
failing with the user generated content and social data that
was entering the stream. And companies that were creating
social filters like Twitter, Facebook, MySpace and others
largely actually find great content, find great information
by using their friends as a social filter. Once again what
we believe is that we are experiencing another phase of
information overload, where the amount of user generated
content of social data that is available to all of us, it's
accessible, is overwhelming stream. And so what we do at
Gravity is that we listen to users, we observe them, we take
a look at what you are saying on Twitter, who you are
following, what they are saying, what you are liking on
Facebook or you are sharing and we build a holistic
understanding of who you are, what you are interested in. So
if you are liking a story about the iPad 2 on TechCrunch or
if you are checking at a local sushi restaurant or if you
tweet about, about the surface and
[inaudible], we can build a really great profile to
understand who you are. From that, what we end up doing is
we partner with third parties as a platform, so that they
can tap into that data and then personalize their
experiences or adapt them to users that access their site.
So in the future, I kind of imagine this world where you
don't go to accessing internet sites or applications where
they are all one-size-fits-all, like going to see New York
Times or going to see ESPN, it actually adapts to you and
your interests. So the best content for you starts to hit
surface to top and some of the noise gets suppressed, so
that's what we are doing at Gravity.
So the whole notion of like what data users give and then
what they get back for, that's interesting because it's
really hot right now. Everybody is talking about, oh you
know are people stealing people's data and are they treating
people's data kind of inappropriately. And so there is a lot
of work kind of amongst standards bodies right now to say,
hey how should our industry, which is dependent on data,
like everything we do at some level depends on users giving
us data and then us making something interesting out of it
and spitting it back. How should we treat it like, what are
the opt-out for users and how much should users know about
kind of what happens to their data, how we are processing it
and how easily, like I said, should they be able to delete
it. So one of the things kind of interesting is most users,
they probably don't care what happens with their data as
long as they understand what the expectation of that
application is. So you know that is look at like the
difference in the evolution to use two companies that are
not in this panel between Facebook and Twitter, right.
Twitter started as a very, very public data system, like
user gives data, the user expects that it's going to the
public. And Facebook started as a private data system, users
gives data and they expect that it's going to be private.
And Facebook has had a lot of difficulty trying to move over
to making that expectation of privacy, all of a sudden,
become public. Whereas Twitter has had this really easy
road, because they just created this default expectation
with users upfront, it's like "hey your data is public and
that's what the users thought they were getting." So I think
that at the end of the day with the users, it's just about
like setting expectations, it's like they had expectations
that the data is public or that it's private and I think it'
s very hard to switch from private to public, it's much
easier to develop public to private.
Yeah I will follow up on what Seth was saying that I think
one really interesting thing about this question is that the
cultural norms around the value that people perceive and the
risk that people perceive of giving up their data is
changing dramatically. I mean if you take a look at the mid
to late 90s, there are a lot of people who say, I don't feel
comfortable giving my credit card to a website and now that'
s changed and you see that not only with information that
people are willing to share with the service, but
information that people are willing to share with the
public. And this is a really great opportunity I think for
startups, because when companies do come out, they have an
existing community with existing cultural norms and it's
hard to change that within the community even though the
overarching cultural norms are changing. And so for example,
Google, when we switched from begin able to have user
accounts and associate your user history with those
accounts, it was very difficult to do. And we had to do a
lot of communications and a lot of putting controls into
place. I think new search engines not launched today will
launch with the idea of having your search history
associated with your account from the get-go opted out. And
so I think that there is a really nice opportunity for
startups as these culture norms continue to evolve at this
rapid pace.
So, personalization means different things to different
people and I think one of the challenges of having this
discussion is when Amit says personalization versus when
Babak says personalization might be different things to
them, and it might be different things to you guys as well,
so keep that in mind if you have questions at the end when
we have a question period. So, I will start the next
question with Amit and if one of the other guys want to jump
in afterwards, feel free, which is, you know there was a lot
of talk about social graph and others, more and more talk
about an interest graph out there and so how is the interest
graph used for the internet and personalization on the
internet.
Sure, so my background before was at Myspace in growing that
company and starting to see where there was an incredible
amount of data about users mainly, who they were connected
with and so that was really the premise behind the social
graph as being able to understand who the user is and who
they are attached to and then understand that way to
detachment, because we may have hundreds of friends, but
there is only a few that were very closely associated with.
What the interest graph does is it gets a notion of what we
are attached to, so what sports do we like, what industries
are we interested in, what locations are we interested in as
well, and understand the way to detachment that you have to
those things, those topics of interest. And with the social
graph, we have seen these unbelievably amazing experiences
and value that's been unlocked with it, on sites like
Facebook as well as all the applications that access it.
With the interest graph, we will see similarly these
unbelievably valuable applications of it where as we use a
mobile app or as we access an internet website by
understanding who the user is, what their interests are, we
can actually start to dynamically adapt that site to that
user. And as a result, you have a really engaging and
amazing experience, where you see a lot less of the noise
that you typically see on web pages and a lot more of things
that will actually interest you. So that's how we see an
interest graph. And one of the things that I think - a
nuance with what we do, as we actually attach people within
that graph, so if you look at semantic technology, the way
that that works, there is an otology which is a dictionary
of terms that relate to each other. So where Kobe Bryant is
a player for the Lakers which is in NBA team is also a
celebrity in Los Angeles, and so those all exist as notes
within otology anthology. What we do is we actually layer in
a people graph on top of those interests and those topics,
so we understand what people are interested and then we can
help you actually traverse through that graph based on
common interest with friends. So all of us may be interested
in Stanford football and because I am also interested in the
iPad2, if you look at your relationship with me and our
common interest in Stanford football, you can actually
direct somebody to the iPad2 via those kinds of inferences.
So there is a lot of complexity that goes into it, but it
just goes to show there is a lot of power within it too or
as we start to apply that, we will start to actually be able
to filter all this information that we are once again
experiencing this overload with on the internet today.
So I think in the internet industry, there is the buzzword
at the moment and interest graph is definitely the buzzword
at the moment. And I also think that when any given person
in the internet industry says interest graph, they probably
have no clue what they are talking about, it's probably
different from the next person next to them, so -
[Overlapping]
But I guess I will say that, they just think, like you and
your personal interest graph and you know what you are
talking about, but everybody else's definition of interest
got that it is probably very different in New York. And so
when you think about, I guess the way I approach it is, you
think about people's relationship with other people, so it's
like you have got your very, very close circle of friends.
And you are probably, like you SMS with that,
[inaudible], you call them. Then you have, you are kind of
second order friends, it's like the people who you wish you
cud keep in touch with, but you don't have time to keep in
touch with. Now a lot of the social stuff in the web today
has done a really, really good job of keeping you in touch
with kind of your close friends, and you are now like with
the advent of Facebook and to something Twitter and
something that was in general second older friends, really
good job, you know MySpace is same thing right. But then
there are all these other people who you probably share
common interest with that you could learn from and you just
don't have a good way to learn from those people today. And
if you think about all the social stuff that's really kind
of default, happened in the web today, it's about your
friends. But the thing is I am interested like I am a pilot,
so I am interested in airplanes, and I personally gotten
into bicycle links, I am interested like you know bicycles.
The thing is only one of my other friends is a pilot and
only one of my other friends really just rides bicycles. So
I can't use my social graph to learn about cool stuff around
airplanes or bicycles. So what I need to do is somehow find
these other people who I overlap with from an interest
perspective and learn from them about bicycles and
airplanes, right. And so I think like in my world of
interest graph, it's how can you use the fact that like
maybe you and I are both interested in flying airplanes and
then how it connect us out there in the internet, then I can
discover cool content or cool new experiences because of
that. So like Bill Gurley and Max Levchin were recently on a
panel at Goldman Sachs Technology Conference, and they made
a very similar point, they were kind of like, look there is
Google all the way over here and like I know I am looking
for it, it's algorithmic and it's like I want to find out
about airplanes and an algorithm helps me find it. And there
is kind of Facebook over here and it's like these are my
friends and maybe I have some interest over lots of my
friends like we like the same kind of music, but we really
don't care and my friends don't care about the same thing,
like bicycling as I do. There is some middle ground which is
based on people and based on learning about our interest
based on people and that has not been done well yet. Like I
know you are working on it and the ways we are working on
it, lot of people are trying to figure out how to do that
middle ground.
[Informal Talk]
I want to follow up what Seth was talking about. The
definition of interest graph, I think changes from, not have
been just one company to another company, from one person to
another person. And the interest comes from the fact that
how interest graph is defined both on the domains that it
covers, let it be from peoples' interests versus items as we
call it like items can be a place, it can be a brand, it can
be a company. And how these relationships are sit up, it
will have deep impact on what the interest graph is going to
be used for, just because somebody mentions on their
Facebook page that I am interested in movies, I mean it
doesn't mean a whole lot. And just because they say I am
interested in rock band, doesn't again the definition of
that changes and how in each graph you talk about, I mean
literally the reliability of that information, the
[inaudible] of that information, you could just say that you
know and I'll say, the inverse of that, actually I don't
like rock music, I mean how those things are sit up in
interest graph would actually have implications on how these
stuff can be used. Talking about notion of personalization
and interest graph can be used for multiple things, I mean
you can just find information that matters to you, based on
how the graph is set up for a particular entity for a
particular, let's say brand, like CNN or a place versus how
your friends perceive it, these are completely different
things and I don't know if this is going to be one single
company who is going to have the overarching encompassing
more interest, does it all for everybody. I think it is
much, much more interesting and useful, if you have a focus
set of graph, that are built for certain things and have a
very rich and deep understanding of how these relationships
are set up, so they can come back and use it for a specific
purpose, because it's just you know how
[inaudible] originally in old days and it was a counter
mechanism to find out what the reliability of a particular
keyword was as it relates to other websites. And same thing
with the notion of interest graph, to me it's just a lot
more complex, because these relationships change and these
relationships are evolving as also people evolve with it. So
yeah, I mean there are just different definitions of it and
there are different use cases based on how you set up your
graph itself.
Let me agree with Seth on the buzzword aspect and also use
the basic principle underlying the shift between the social
graph to the interest graph to help you come up with new
buzzword. So the idea is that we have basically a set of
notes and a set of edges within the notes. And the
transition from the social graph to the interest graph is
essentially, you are labeling some of these notes with their
interests. Well you can label them with other things for
example reputations and so then you have a reputation graph
or expertise and then you have an expertise graph and then
you can also do things like label the edges themselves in
terms of the types of relationship or the type of
information fuzz along those relationships. And so there is
benefit around generating new buzzwords, but also to think
about new kinds of information interaction to happen on
graphs just using that principle of continuing to further
label these notes and these edges.
But with full disclosure Seth is one of the advisors, so we
learn a lot from him.
[Informal Talk]
Actually I tried to be full disclosure, August Capitals and
investor in Gravity, Amit's company and I tried to be an
investor in Seth's company and had I known you other guys, I
probably would have tried to invest in - there you go. So,
what would the ultimate personalized experience look like?
What opportunities will emerge when like everything in your
life is captured within the digital realm? So why don't we
start with Seth on this one.
Well, I will answer that question, if you can first tell me
what the ultimate un-personalized experience will look like.
Somebody, who doesn't use the Internet.
So I mean I think that's a very hard question to answer.
This is a little bit of brave new world like what could it
be 5 to 10 years from now and maybe you can add into the
answer like is it too much at that point, is it actually a
bad thing.
So I mean I will give a couple of non-answers that answers
somewhat related questions. I think first is, I think right
now algorithms for personalization are not very good. I
think you have essentially two classes of algorithms. One is
item-based collaborative filtering which is used on things
like Amazon. And the second you have model-based type
recommendations which I used for a lot of others site,
presumably with you guys and with you guys. And these
algorithms have been around for a very long time and there
is a lot of opportunity for new innovations from the
algorithmic side. And I think when you get those kinds of
innovations, you'll have much more highly specific type of
recommendations. So, that's one as I think there is room for
innovation on the outer
[inaudible] side, so that you have a much higher specificity
and it's the kind of thing that you will note when you see
it like Google search results were so much better than
Altavista search results. So I think that's one kind of
brave new world of personalization. I think second is as
more kinds of data be moved to the web, you have a lot of
kinds of data that are not amenable to traditional keyword
search and a much more amenable to personalized
recommendations. I mean music being an example, but job
search being an example. I mean there is some stat like 80%
of people are passively looking for a job, real estate, so
on. And so, when you combine these two and not to mention
things like video, for example, where for entertainment
needs, it doesn't make sense to do a keyword based search.
So, when you have this combination of better algorithms for
personalization and new types of data that are much more
amenable for personalization that's I think the two trends
that will point towards the ultimate personalization
experience. If I knew the specific answer to that, I'd
probably just started company around that.
I think as Seth said, it's pretty difficult, I mean these
things, we know things are going to get more personalized
because there is the problem of information overload. As
Amit was talking about, it's pretty obvious, I mean it's
just, you are living
[inaudible] as more and more people are sharing and there is
more and more, you are getting bombarded by information. I
mean right now, we all, I think live in a society which is
just ADD-driven, I mean attention deficit disorder is a real
thing. I mean everyone is just all constant, getting mobile
with Twitter and Facebook and new sites and there is just so
much happening. I think the way we see it at least, I don't
know if it's going to be 20, 30 or even like years from now.
But one thing that we would like to work toward is that this
notion of the information fund and you in a right place at
the right time, obviously real-time such that we would
understand your relationship with things that you care about
and as they are moving around, as they are changing, if an
event triggers that would really, really interest you, and
we would find you and deliver it to you, whether you are on
the web, whether you are on the go, much like I mean the
vision would be, I mean somebody who care of you when, you
are on the bed. You don't need to sift through piles and
piles of documents, I mean right now I mean most attorneys
or executives and whatever they have, assistants who
actually sift through stuff and say, these are the things
you should pay attention to, these are meetings right here,
make sure you read this document, I mean that's what they
do, but they are human beings who sifting through that
information and they also understand your priorities. So I
think a personalized role, I mean I will tie around
[inaudible] personalizing role around you is such that you
would find information of the
[inaudible] you are on to go and we would actually try to do
an experience of, we are very big on serendipity, I mean it'
s actually search, so we would actually do think on your
behalf when you are not thinking and try to deliver
information as it would relate to you, serendipitously.
[Informal Talk]
I mean just sort of take it a little bit away from being too
conceptual. I think that there are some things that we are
seeing today where personalization is actually very
effective in the today and in near future and then to sort
of look where we go ahead in a few years. We will talk about
that in a second too. But even today, I think if you look at
practical applications of personalization, music is one,
where it is very effective. So my background, in MySpace, I
ran MySpace Music when I was there, it was one of my
responsibilities. And we were part of this revolution where
music became very social. And I think that before that, you
saw this, I mean even to take a step back from that for a
second though, one of the things that personalization does
very effectively is it helps us sift through a list of
options. And so, early on, even before social DJs and
editors would help us sift through a list of options, so
with the radio DJ or an MTV DJ that's how we discovered
great music. A new phase happened when social entered the
scene, so people were either sharing mix tapes or you were
creating play list and sharing that on MySpace where you
discover an ever increasing pool of music via your friends
as a filter for finding better options. And today with
Pandora, there is a product a lot of us used where you
actually are receiving personalized music. And I think what
they do very effectively is they don't get too caught up by
going too deep in the sites, because you can very much go
too deep to the point that you are not finding a practical
application things. But what they have done with the music
genome project is that they used humans to actually
categorize the content and then they understand based on
your behavior, what you are listening to, what you are
liking and disliking, they are able to take you down a
recommendation path and that is a very, very effective
personalization experience. Another one which has been used
on Yahoo today, is their front page, they have a Today unit,
where they run millions of different permutations and call
it what you will or it may not be the much advanced science
behind what they are showing you, even if it's just basic
demographic data, targeted data or location targeted data.
But they see 200% to 1,000% uplift an improvement for
personally targeted versus non-targeted content in that
space. So, what we are doing is similarly, we are trying to
imply that technology where I imagine this future which is
not too far off where you go to the New York Times or you go
to ESPN or you go to yahoo.com and every single one of us
has a slightly different experience that's catered to us,
based on the likelihood that I live in LA, I like the
Lakers, I like golf and I like tennis, if there are good
stories, those should be the ones that are surfaced at the
top on ESPN for me, instead of the one-size-fits-all just
like you are picking up a newspaper experience that we get
today. So I think that that's something that's not very far
off. Way in the future and not even that far off too is I
think where things get very-very heavily dynamically
personalized, because we start to get smarter and smarter as
we take these incremental steps. And in some way, every
story, every link that you see could be somehow waited to
you and with an understanding of, you are certainly yield
optimizing to the person, is there a likelihood that they
are going to want to see this or click on this. And then it
gets smarter and adapts based on your reactions to that. So
we should not be seeing the same group-on deals every
everyday. We should not be seeing the same websites as we
visit them. The applications that we open up should be
somehow different personalized to each of us, even if its
basic is the location that we are in with stuff that Babak
is doing. So, I think that thinking about things at that
practical level really gets you sense for the power of
personalization in even your turn.
So something Meebo is working on right now is this notion of
web check-ins just because we are distributed through so
many sites, so we want to start letting users track into
those sites. And tracking into the sites is completely
irrelevant, who cares, so that's called check-in, right.
[inaudible] kind of question is what can you do with that
data, like what interesting experience can you deliver to
user? And one of the interesting experiences that we wanted
to deliver that user is let's say that you go to like, this
is actually me, six months ago, when I knew exactly nothing
about bicycling, except that I kind of liked this notion of
bicycling. I went to bicycling.com, which is the only site I
knew about bicycling. And when I checked in, as we know we
had a product that I don't like messing around with, it's
not really --. And when I checked in, it showed me other
people who have checked in on bicycling.com too. I am like,
oh okay well may be those people who have also checked in on
bicycling.com know about other co-bicycling sites, so I
click someone's picture. I will enter another profile stage.
Oh they found this other bicycling site called
competitivecyclist.com, so then I go there, that's an
interesting site, because now I can start buying cool
bicycling gear from Competitive Cyclist and by the way now
Competitive Cyclist just picked up a new customer. And so
it's literally users discovering other people with their
same interest, right back to the interest graph. And being
basically suggested content or other websites that would be
interested to them. And so the way I think about this kind
of the interest graph or personalization of the web like
what Amit talked about is a lot of, how can you make the
site experience better, like New York Times better, how can
you make yahoo's front page better. Another thing that, we
are thinking about is look like most people are just really
freaking bored, I mean how often do you guys sit in front of
your computer, you are like you have 15 minutes to kill, so
you like
[inaudible] standby website, like for me it's CNN, when I am
bored it's like CNN.com, go, okay alright. And I am still
bored and I have another ten minutes to kill, newyorktimes.
com, go. Okay still little bit bored, I am running out of
sites though, maybe I will try to Google Reader quickly. It'
s like you want to find other cool stuff and so I think if
you could leverage what are people interested in and then
hooking them up with other people of similar interests, you
can start suggesting really good content to people that
starts to solve the boredom problem. And at the end of the
day, a lot of what of internet does is just try to solve
boredom.
A quick comment on that, so it suggests that there is a
really tight relationship between personalization and
social.
A few weeks ago, I walked into my 12-year-olds room and I
said, what do you want for breakfast and she said I want
pancakes and I sat there chatting with her for a few
minutes, and then my wife yelled, pancakes are ready and my
younger daughter was like, dad was really weird. And so I
wonder where is there a point on the web, is it, if you add
location into it, if you all the other data you are putting
in like what you are watching on Netflix or what you are
buying at Wal-Mart or whatever it may be, where
personalization has gotten to the point where you are just
like, that's weird, like they know too much about me, and I
am curious how you guys feel about that, is that coming or
are we there or what does that look like.
Let me start by saying that there is an interesting product
there, which is on your mobile phone to implicitly infer
your interest at the moment and then broadcast it to your
friends and so your app fix that you are going to like
pancakes, it will tell your parents. In terms of weird, I
think we will progressively be more weird, I think that what
we think is weird now will become normal.
I mean weird like some people might consider that privacy
was inundated or what is privacy --.
Yeah I think cultural norms and privacy, I have definitely
changed dramatically over last ten years, and will continue
to change, in ways that will surprise us when we have kids
and so mean there is a real change and there is a real
intergenerational change in terms of perception of privacy.
And I think to add to that, you mentioned when people were
scared of putting their credit card numbers online and I
remember when I started at Myspace, people were scared of
putting a photo online or putting their real name online.
And I was scared, I don't know
[inaudible] do this. But once I did, I started to value in
it. And so I think you know the sort of stage that we are
out with personalization is somewhat similar where, what is
happening right now is there is a fear in the unknown, like
right now we project these potential disaster scenarios
because we don't know what's going to happen. And so I think
what will more logically end up happening is what you have
to do is first educate the user, as to what's happening. You
show them value for what's happening as a result of that.
You build trust in your relationship with them. And then
they are going to be a little bit more forthcoming with
their data. I don't know if or when we will get to a place
where everything is completely transparent, I can't imagine
that being the case. So I think that we will have certain
things about us, if it's health related maybe financially
related, maybe not or kept a little bit more secure, a
little bit more private. But I think that like every sort of
disruptive technology will deal with those hurdles as they
come and we will figure out the right way to react to them.
But I think that by far the value that we will get out of it
very much outweighs the risks that we are taking. So it's
very much in our interest to push those boundaries and just
try to figure out where that equilibrium is.
So I do have a weird experience that I can share actually,
it actually relates to your old company, MySpace.
[Informal Talk]
No, but in general, actually I want to talk about this
notion that I mean, really communication of that, and people
knowing what's been done to them, I mean that would define
how weird it is or how you know beautiful or how
serendipitous it is. If you search for my name online, so
you will find Facebook page, which is no problem, I advise
them to share my name to world and there is link there. And
then there is just other site who apparently got my data-
minds, age, where I have been, blah, blah, blah from my old
account on MySpace. And I had no clue that MySpace was doing
this, I mean that level of data sharing --
[Informal Talk]
They were probably following it.
But that's the thing, it's most likely was crawlers. But
this notion that the company is taking responsibility and
actually taking steps to not letting these things happen, I
mean like it or not --
[Informal Talk]
I think it's interesting, because it was in this time of
change, where you weren't necessarily aware that was
happening, but it was because the information is public, the
same way that Twitter is now very obviously public
information, at the time that wasn't necessarily perceived
as obviously public.
I mean that level of unwanted sharing of information could
be communicated as user. Someone could have sent an e-mail,
I mean these are techniques that I think if people take
actions to them, it would actually take out the weirdness
part. I mean I would have been totally cool if I got an e-
mail from MySpace, hey look, there is a chance that our
website is getting scraped, your information will be out
there, come back and actually check off these privacy things
on my
[inaudible] lock it down. I mean one simple e-mail would
have solved the whole thing. Now I am on this hunting, on
this quest to somehow tell this website to remove my
information which you already scraped and it's already in
their hands and I don't know what to do with it.
Oh I think is, I mean expect MySpace to do that I mean for
one crawling technology.
[Informal Talk]
I think what this conversation does highlight is the culture
is moving to where people just expect like, hey if it's
public, it's public, if it's private, it's private, they
have an expectation they get served that way. The thing that
we all have to deal with this in industry is there are going
to be 1%-2% of users who become very, very offended by what
has happened, even if we set it up the right way. And so we
need to be able to serve those people, who become very, very
offended and going to make it right with them and so every
company is got to figure that out.
So we talked a little bit briefly about personalization
based on social graph, we talked about personalization based
on interest graph, and maybe the next one to talk about is
based on location. There are all these physical check-in
services like Foursquare and Gowalla and Facebook has places
and different ones like that. So I am curious what you guys
think, we will start with Babak this time, what is kind of
the location based, personalization maybe compare that to
how people consider personalization on the web and what will
be the main challenges for our location based
personalization.
So there this notion that I mean we are seeing this right
now, I mean you normally know your places that you will got
it around the place you live, the place you go to school and
probably on your way. I mean to me, you are living in a city
that just lights are all off, you don't know where to find
things that would be really cool to you, I mean find the
next burger joint, the next
[inaudible] really will match your interest. All these are
the things that currently what's the service that would
allow you to define them for you and let you know. Aside
from the fact that, if you are leaving in Hollywood and you
have personal assistant who is just walking around actually
find stuff for you to do, so I think we are living in an age
I think the next generation of technologies are needed to
basically to help you find much like you know companies like
just Gravity or others are doing it to find other contents
that would match your interest that are on the web, we can
actually find them in actual physical places. The problem
with the old school way of doing things, in your CF base
like how Amazon and Netflix were doing it was that, I mean
they collaborate filtering, we are doing things, you have to
have lot of signals established between how people relate to
places, so all these check-ins are wonderful, but it's just
there is not enough data being captured right now to
actually use the old school way of doing things. Actually,
we have something we can actually put on the screen. There
is a graph that actually talks about this point. So talking
about challenges, so from the perspective of, is it
interesting, is it useful, absolutely, I think it will move
on offline commerce, it will move a lot of things that it
will help you to find places or deals or whatever that would
match truly your interest as
[inaudible]. But then the challenges are this, you know don'
t have enough signals that are established to be able to use
normal way of doing recommendations to find that. Actually
if you have the previous slide photos, I am going to show
you just, we are doing two slides there. So this is the heat
map of us basically analyzing roughly about 500,000 users as
they have interacted different places by rating them. This
is an Bay Area, so if you are living in Bay Area in local
places, people can do a pretty good job of doing potentially
recommendations, because there is enough people who have
interacted at places that, if you like so and so and the
other person likes so and so and this other extra thing, we
can also recommend it to you. But then if you go to the next
slide, sort of challenge is, but doing that on a large
scale, there is an inherent problem that is people are not
moving, people that are in Palo Alto are not checking-in in
New York as often as you want to. So the information is not
traveling, so it's only 15% of people are basically rating
or checking into places that are not local to them. So if we
know a lot of good things about you, when you are in Palo
Alto, now you get up and go to London, let's say or even New
York.
So what you are saying is you need the interest graph
overlaying on this and then everything work great.
Yeah because, exactly if you have the DNA of places, I mean
it's much like how Pandora does it for music, if you know
how to describe places then that would change everything,
because then it doesn't matter how many
[inaudible] signals between places, it's a matter of if you
know how to discover a place and if you have an interest
graph that evolves for the user, then you are free to roam
around, you can just move around everywhere. And right now
we have almost 90% level accuracy if you can find places
that would actually match your actual interest. Anyway you
go.
I think what Babak
[inaudible] is really cool and I very, very like. It's going
to be an awesome value proposition when you can actually
sort of be guided around within locations. The way that I
like to look at it and it is similar to what Seth was saying
earlier that it's kind of, the location is somewhat, it's
another data point within your graph where in a strange way
like location conceptually, be it physical or digital or
somewhat the same right like. When we go to a town and we
have bunch of options for restaurants or bars to go to, it's
almost similar to going online and we have bunch of options
for websites to visit or even being added individual
website, if it's a new site or whatever might be and having
a bunch of options for what might be a cool story for me.
And so what we are all trying to do is figure out how do we
help you navigate through be it a physical or digital
location based on what's going to be personally relevant to
you. And that maybe what's the right way of determining the
shortest path from you to the thing that you are probably
going to like the most and there are lots of different
algorithms, there are lots of different methods for helping
you find that. Sometimes it's the simplest ones that are
most effective, but the way that we tend to see it is, if
it's a physical location or even a link or a website itself
that's something that what we are trying to do is help you
navigate that sort of be your guide to help you discover
really cool things on it that are going to be catered to
your interests.
So with the internet and kind of interfacing with the real
world, there is this category of company that's begun to
spring up a little bit, which makes physical goods, it's
like Webkinz is the best first example, they make a toy and
usually the margins on that kind of physical good product is
driven down to zero, really fast as competitors copy them.
But then what they do is they interface the toy in some way
with the internet and they create network effect or some
kind of community for that physical toy and then they keep
their margins up on the physical good side. So it's an
example of the internet interfacing with the real world. And
I think location is just it's another example of the
internet interfacing with the real world, but I think you
can go far beyond like I am at a restaurant right now,
because we all stare it like the dancing pixels of our
screens, a lot of hours of the day. But there are also a lot
of hours of the day where we forget about like where we are,
we are just doing the stuff in the real world maybe we are
in transit, maybe we are reading a magazine, lo and behold.
Maybe we are like doing real kind of human interaction
things. And so I think the question is how can the internet
provide you some richer experience or some more information
or help you discover more cool stuff or connect you with
other people based on the actions that you are taking in the
real world. And the best example of kind of how this is
beginning to work kind of abstract a location into just like
interface with real world is QR codes in Japan. Like that's
actually pretty close, right because it's not just a limited
restaurant, it's like oh I just saw this ad in a magazine
and I want to learn more about it, or oh I am at the store
and I want to learn more about the product scan, discover.
So I think if you abstract a little bit away from the GO
notion into just the interface of internet with real world
notion, I don't know what it's going to look like in
America, maybe there will be QR codes but something is going
to happen there it's going to be very interesting.
Yeah I will also use this since Babak and Amit gave a good
answer to the location question, I will do the same ASAP and
use this to say going to another observation, which is one
of the things that made kind of this location, location
aware computing, possible, is the fact that we all now have
computers with sensors or something, we have computers that
know our location. And that provides a tremendous
opportunity around location. The more sensors we have on our
computers, the more kind of opportunities there become not
only around location, but around all sorts of stuff. So you
add a temperature sensor, you add an accelerometer, you don'
t even think about your phone as a computer, but when cars
start opening up APIs then you have different types of
location.
[Audience]
I mean even more specifically I mean why is it somebody
building an app to just show me the McDonalds when I am back
in there, so and third party --.
[Audience]
And so I think in general kind of, I will not answer the
question of where location based personalization is, but I
will suggest there are other kinds of opportunities for
personalization will arise as more sensors get added to
different kinds of computers.
[Audience]
Augmented realities, see it's just another way of
interacting, I mean the data that you show when you look
through different screen, if you come from anywhere,
interest graph, all discussions around this notion that
instead of showing you, when you are looking through a lens,
instead of showing you hundred different dots, interest
graph will help you to show that only five that will
actually be relevant to you. So it makes that experience ten
times better because their screen is not collaborated by
irrelevant stuff, that's it.
[Audience]
Well that's not interest graph, that's the notion of search.
Well I will answer that question. Some students of mine a
few years ago said they are starting a company, there is a
toolbar that collects your entire browsing history and then
it will use it to personalize set results. And at the time,
I kind of tried to dissuade them from doing that, because I
didn't think that people would be interested in sharing
their whole browsing history with a startup that nobody
knows about, they have enough problems with that, the kinds
of things that we were doing with Google and so to trust the
information to this startup. So they came back to me last
week and they said so now we have about 8 million users and
I said how did you get 8 million users? And they said well
we launched this feature that people can also share your
entire browsing history with everybody you know on Facebook
and that made it viral. And so the fact that I was pretty
sure that people wouldn't do it this far. But people, the
thing that made it work with people did it even further than
that. So it's very hard to do legislation when there are
such shifting cultural norms and also when there are
differences in terms of generationally, so a lot of the
group who were doing this or younger. Now where I think
legislation may be able to go is be able to do things like
required control, required choice, required transparency,
and required data portability. And those four things I think
despite like to be able to use a service and choose to not
have your personally identified in the people in the mission
shared it's something that's nice so to be able to choose to
say I don't want to use the service anymore I want to move
to another service and I want to move my data with me. I
think those four things are really where our legislation can
happen.
Great discussion and thank you so much. And is on the
monetization of this personalization services so what do you
guys see as the way that companies can actually have --.
Would it be a female model that you know a lot of time uses
a link to pay the services or should it be like more
enterprise level? The big companies for advertisement based
I guess this organization would work but how do you see like
the companies that should be able to make profit in the
future probably like in the next two or three years but in
10 years' time would users be really like paid to this and
be pumping their lives?
At the broad level that we have been talking about around
like there is this generalized notion of an interest graph
and you can do lots of different stuff with it. And I think
it's very hard to pin and therefore this is how you will
make money because the best way to make money on products
and the internet is usually figure out the very specific way
users use your product and then they have money off of that.
So like in the example I gave it the way we are thinking
about interest graph like let's say that you did have me and
I was at bicycling.com and I clicked on someone's picture
probably because I want to find other bicycling stuff. Oh
that's sounds like a search. Right I mean and on going to
that person's profile because I want to find other bicycling
stuff. So there is probably room to do a keyword bid between
specialized tracked in survey and say hey who is willing to
pay the most to get me to go to their site, right. So that
probably looks like a search monetization play. But you know
they probably have ideas on how to monetize you know making
you in your times a more relevant experience based on the
interest graphs. So I think it just depends on the actual
expression of the data to the user.
I agree.
[Audience]
And partly ignorance scaring me a little but I am thinking
of emerging markets and I have got Iran and China on the
line. So when you have I mean you can't even speak politics
with CCT liaison in the room when you are dealing with
exactly the Chinese company and when I hear you talk about
almost an AI type of we will find what you want and send it
to your friends. Now see what you are thinking of, like a
kind of bold fear -- as sisters in Iran and sometimes go
postings on Facebook with other went through or without
proper head requirement how does this information is going
to be gathering itself and possibly you know I don't it's
not getting into the world here but we are going to have two
types of users in my opinion in emerging market, one is
going to be someone who doesn't understand what they are
putting in, which is scary and second is going to be someone
who is now what you do have grade which will shoe up the
kind of issue. Big question, right. Yeah it sounds like we
are talking about developed world in this conversation and I
am thinking of you know potential 400 million users.
What I would say to that is I think the potential for all
software technologies not just personalization by this I
mean with Twitter and Facebook and everything, I mean the
potential for surveillance is a real danger to consumers,
not just in the developing world but everywhere. And I don't
really have a good answer for that. I mean I think that
people will continue to build tools that allow people to
express themselves and people will continue to use those
tools and use those tools very publicly and they have
wonders potentials like they can you can build your own
personal brands through this or you can learn a lot through
lots of people communicating. But they also have downsides
which are things like surveillance. And it reminds me so
Richard Feynman said this thing where he went to Thailand
and a Buddhist monk told him to every person is given a key
to heaven and that same key opens the doors to hell and he
said that technology is the same way, is that a lot of the
same technology that enables wonders opportunities also
enables in a various opportunities.
[Audience]
I mean like my mother got berserk, she just went on Facebook
like and someone counted us some picture she put up there
and she responds to the comment with something she should
not have said in public because she had no clue. She thought
she was you know privately answering that person fortunately
my sister saw it, calls my mother as it's like, mom it's
Facebook doing that. You know I think my sister of course
answers me immediately and says can you believe what I just
did. So you know it -- your mother people are going to screw
this stuff up a lot on any new technology and again it kind
of goes back to the tools to try to help people remove this
kind of stuff but it's just risk.
[Audience]
But I think one last comment that is just I think as long as
there are tools there to correct the mistakes you said it
and you can't delete it anymore it's as long as there are
things or we can further more, we can say from now on I don'
t want to share so and so. As long as these tools are there
I think we would give a lot of, I think we should give a lot
of credit to people they can learn and they can pick up
these things very, very quickly and much like you know your
mom pop wouldn't do this anymore because she knows now. You
never know, people also will evolve. I mean we should give
credit to people's intelligence I mean they will get things
one or two mistakes are made and after next the third one
hopefully we are going to turn it up as long as the tools
are there.